nous sommes sur les hauteurs de sainte
marie avec une équipe de la direction de
l'alimentation de l'agriculture et des
forêts venus faire des prélèvements de
légumes sur l'exploitation d'élise et
paca à la recherche de chlordécone tout
ce qu'il m'a nous intéresser c'est de
faire des prélèvements là vous avez pas
d analyse parce que le risque donc les
plus importants on va faire des
prélèvements de légumes racines elysées
cultive patates douces ignames et
dachine des légumes considérés comme à
risque car la partie consommé pousse
dans la terre avant la récolte des
échantillons de chaque légume son
prélevé pour analyse
on va chercher un représenter au mieux
la production de la parcelle donc il
faut que les prélèvements soient
réalisées sur l'ensemble de la surface
de la parcelle et qui ne se focalise pas
sur un seul point
l'ensemble de la procédure dite de
contrôle paquet hygiène ciblé
chlordécone est expliqué en détail à
l'agriculteur on aura les résultats de
ces analyses d'ici une quinzaine de
jours et dans la tente de de ses
résultats on va bloquer la récolte ce qu
on dit qu'on va consignes et la récolte
vous aurez pas le droit de sortir de
produits
si les résultats sont mauvais la récolte
sera détruite pour réaliser paca loin
d'être source d'inquiétude ces contrôles
semblent au contraire rassurant ça fait
bien longtemps alors wattao du cboe moi
c'est une bonne loi avant tout
l'exploitant agricole est le premier
responsable de la qualité de sa
production et donc de sa non toxicité la
daf vient en second contrôle pour
vérifier les bonnes pratiques les
légumes récoltés seront lavés puis
séparés en deux lots le premier sera
analysé le second sera congelé pour
servir en cas de réclamation par exemple
lors des premiers contrôles en 2003
plusieurs récoltes avaient ainsi était
détruite car très contaminée très vite
en quatre ans on arrive à un taux de
conformité pratiquement à zéro pour cent
en conformité tous les ans grâce au fait
que les cultures cultivés dans des
terrains sont à zéro donc quand on vous
dit que les résultats sont sous la lmr
dans 80% des cas elles sont à zéro dans
les 20% restants les taux relevés sont
entre 0 et 20
en dessous des limites maximales de
résidus de chlordécone fixée en france
les fameuses elle est maire